let's go to our daily cancellation um
this is a very important subject and i
believe i have addressed it before on
the show
i don't think i've i've taken the time
to issue a cancellation related to it
i don't think if i have then i'm
repeating myself and just deal with it
stop complaining okay
this is my show don't judge me
so i want to show you something this is
a real photo i took it myself
it's difficult to look at i warn you if
you have kids in the room
i would say have them turn away for a
moment uh
not appropriate for them i don't even
know if they're gonna let me show this
without blurring it out it is pretty
graphic
but okay here we go here's the picture
as you can see there those are shopping
carts
in a walmart parking lot left in the
middle of the parking lot
this is what i stumbled across yesterday
there is a cart corral
not but 20 feet away look at the one
closest to the grass
that's five feet from the receptacle
five feet
this is someone who almost to make a
point
had pushed the cart nearly all the way
there and then said no i can't go any
further
i i i can't i've i can't i've gone too
far
my legs will give out it's too much
um and then they just leave it there and
this was a breezy day yesterday
by the way those are not shopping carts
those are torpedoes
all it takes is an errant wind to send
one of those things crashing into
someone's
side panel it has been
the primary goal of my life and my
life's main ambition
to combat these shopping cart ditchers
to expose them
to punish them to shame them
i i truly believe that the entire the
entirety of a person's character can be
assessed based on what they do with
their shopping carts
after they've unloaded their groceries
it may seem like a small thing but it's
precisely because it's a small thing
that it tells you everything you need to
know see if you cannot be bothered for
the sake of your fellow man
to return your shopping cart to walk 20
feet to return it or
five feet to return the car then we know
that the cutoff
the bar for you for what you're willing
to do for the betterment of society
is somewhere below returning a shopping
cart
you see we we know that the bar is below
that
maybe there are some things you're
willing to do for society
and for your fellow man but it's not
anything as as significant as returning
a cart
i'll put it this way if you're trapped
in a burning building
and a shopping cart ditcher walks by
outside are you gonna have any
confidence that he's gonna run in
and save you no because this is someone
who won't even put his card away
to save your vehicle from getting
scratched you think he's going to risk
his life
no of course he's not which is why if
there was a shopping cart ditcher
trapped in the burning building
i would just leave them to their death
that's a little strong isn't it i'm
coming on a little bit strong let me
i'll pull back just i'll pull back just
a smidge from that
uh here's my point you know
there's there's no excuse uh
so someone said to me yesterday you know
when i was complaining about this
online because this is like i said i'm a
professional this is what i do
someone said we have to make exceptions
for the elderly and disabled and mothers
with children
you know yeah everyone else but make
exceptions for them sorry
no no exceptions first of all if we made
exceptions for old people and women
um then who exactly were holding
accountable here because that's like 85
percent of a grocery store's clientele
but more to the point if a person is
capable
of getting the cart to begin with
walking around the store with it
doing the 19-mile lap around walmart
going back to their car then they're
capable of going back to the car corral
i don't want to hear the excuse
if you've already done all that it's and
it's time to return their car
your cart you can't suddenly go oh i'm
too old
i'm old i can't do it my knees so i've
had
i've had an attack of old suddenly and i
just can't anymore
i've already walked 57 miles to get
everything at walmart but but this
that it's the last 10 feet i simply
can't do it can't do it
no we've seen what you're capable of all
right return the cart gramps
no excuse as for mothers i don't want to
hear that excuse for a minute i've been
shopping
with four kids by myself i might not be
a mother i could be a mother for all you
know these days okay if i choose to be a
mother than i am
whether i am or not i return the cart if
i can do it you can do it it's not that
hard
put the kids in let me explain how this
works
here's the process for any any any any
mothers who are
confused about this put the kids in the
car
put the groceries in the car return the
cart
and then come back to your car and drive
away happily ever after
not hard to do you oh but i don't want
to leave my precious children in the car
alone
you can't leave them in a car while you
walk 15 feet away
really what do you what's gonna happen
when you're when
in that 15 in in the 20 seconds it takes
you to do that what do you think is
going to happen what's the worst case
scenario
what it's it's hot out i can't leave him
in the what do you do when you're at a
gas station do you
do i mean i hope you don't leave the car
running while you pump the gas do you
take all the kids out at the gas station
all right kids get out come stand here
at pump five i can't leave you in the
car alone
come on don't be ridiculous
i actually had a mother tell me once
that she doesn't want to get arrested
for leaving her car's
kids in the car alone while she returns
to car right because there are cops in
the parking
lot with measuring tape and if you if
you walk more than seven feet from your
car to return
a cart uh they're gonna arrest you on
the spot sure i'm sure that's happened
man it's that's happened millions of
times i'm sure it's a really common
occurrence
stop stop with your excuses take
ownership take accountability
i'm not you know there may be some
excuses let me backtrack a little bit
if you get abducted on your way to
return the cart okay
if you get raptured in the in in the
parking lot of a super fresh while
you're returning your cart then okay i
guess god in that case will be the
shopping cart ditcher and i'll have
words with him about that at a later
date
but or even if you're say batman okay
and
and you're in the parking lot you see
the bat signal
and uh the riddler is about to blow up
city hall and you've got to go and
okay fine i'll allow for that but aside
from those if you are not abducted
raptured dead or batman return your
damned
cart use scoundrels
scoundrels and rap scallions the lot of
you
that's what i say canceled uh
and we will leave it there that was what
was that ten minutes on shopping carts
okay
you know there's nothing else going on
in the world it's not like there's more
important news happening in the world
so i'm going to carve out some time to
talk about shopping carts because this
is an important issue
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the entire
country if you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a like and a
subscribe to our youtube channel so you
don't miss out on any of our content